alors on va commencer par la première
question sur l'actualité de la semaine
c'est patrick de cabariot qui
m'interrogent en me disant l'article 24
est un sujet de polémique
énorme que pensez vous de cette
polémique et une messieurs darmanin est
il l'homme de la situation
alors que sa majorité est en train de se
déchirer notre police n'est pas
responsable de tous les maux de la
société
patrick a raison l'autre police n'est
pas responsable de tous les maux de la
société et il faut apporter à notre
police le soutien le plus absolu
il faut dire aussi que gérald darmanin
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur de la
situation
le rôle d'un ministre de l'intérieur ce
n'est pas baptisé la confrontation entre
la police les forces de l'ordre et les
citoyens
le rôle d'un ministre l'intérieur c'est
d'apaiser le pays et tous les grands
ministres même derrière notre pays tous
les grands préfet police notre pays sont
ceux qui ont réussi à bien employé les
forces de l'ordre et à ne pas les
surexplosés et dans cette question dans
cette situation nous avons non seulement
la grande montée de la violence dans ces
manifestations qui doivent être réprimés
avec la plus grande fermeté
mais nous avons aussi un vrai problème
de commandement et on peut pas ignorer
que gérald darmanin qui est le chef des
forces de l'ordre n'est pas à la hauteur
de la situation
lorsqu'on est à la hauteur de la
situation je le redis on ne met pas le
feu au pays et au fond ce qu'il restera
de gérald darmanin comme d'ailleurs des
manuels macron c'est qu'ils sont et le
ministre et le président du désordre
dans un pays comme le nôtre le désordre
la pire des choses et aujourd'hui nous
en sommes là pour ce qui est de
l'article 24
la question de l'article 24 était celle
de la protection des forces de l'anp je
suis pas certain que l'article tel qu'il
avait été rédigée très mal rédigée fait
de manière très expéditive et pu régler
le problème de la protection des forces
de l'ordre
les mesures elles doivent être beaucoup
plus forte beaucoup plus audacieuse
insupportable aujourd'hui que certaines
aux policiers certaine aux gendarmes
soient personnellement prises pour
cibles que leurs familles soient prises
pour cibles et qu'ils soient menacés de
mort voire agresser nous avons des
dizaines et des dizaines d'agressions
jeu quotidienne de nos forces de l'ordre
il faut donc les protéger mais il faut
plus qu'un petit article 24 écrit avec
les pieds pour dire les choses comme
elles sont pour protéger nos forces de
l'ordre
mesures beaucoup plus forte qui permette
de même de sanctionner les délinquants
qui s'en prennent à l'autorité de la
république parce que derrière l'uniforme
c'est l'autorité de la république est
donc cet article 24
c'est tout ça pour rien tout ça pour ne
pas avoir permis de mieux protéger les
forces de l'ordre pour avoir mis le pays
dans un état de fracturation total c'est
à croire au final que gérald darmanin et
le président de la république trouve un
plaisir singulier à dresser les français
les uns contre les autres c'est le cas
depuis les gilet jaune depuis toutes les
les annonces qui ont été faites
successives jusqu'à la question de cet
article 24 pour au final ne plus rien
comprendre à rien puisque le premier
ministre a lui-même annoncé que cet
article serait réécrit retirer on sait
pas très bien en méprisant au passage
totalement le processus parlementaire
puisque vous savez nous sommes dans une
démocratie parlementaire et que dans une
démocratie parlementaire sont les
parlementaires qui écrivent la loi qui
écrivait un article de loi
c'est pas le premier ministre sont pas
ses ministres et c'est pas le président
de la république c'est pour ça qu'il ya
un pouvoir législatif et le pouvoir
exécutif au fond tout cela résume un
amateurisme extrêmement profond parfois
à mes prix considérable des règles de
notre démocratie
et puis je le dis une capacité
aujourd'hui devenu un vrai problème pour
eux qui est une capacité à attiser le
pays il savait personne ne peut se
réjouir de voir chaque week end des
situations d'une extrême tension dans
notre pays ni les forces de l'ordre ni
les citoyens et donc pour sortir de cela
il faut avoir un ministre de l'intérieur
qui soit à la hauteur qui jouent pas un
petit jeu politique personnelle qui se
donne pas des grands airs qui n'est pas
capable d'assumer et qui vraiment assure
son rôle de ministre l'intérieur
c'est à dire garantir la sécurité des
forces de l'ordre et la sécurité des
citoyens
la seconde question concerne toujours la
police c'est andré de bordeaux qui la
pause
la séquence sur la police à laquelle
nous venons d'assister fracture notre
pays c'est ce que je vais bien me dire à
l'instant
quelles leçons en tirer sur
l'organisation sur le fonctionnement sur
le commandement de la police
que faut-il revoir vous vous rendrez
c'est ce que j'évoquais à l'instant
et vous avez raison la question du
commandement est une question
essentielle
c'est un peu facile de renvoyer la
responsabilité sur les forces de l'ordre
alors qu'il y à des chefs qui eux
doivent assumer la responsabilité
c'est vrai pour les préfets c'est vrai
pour le préfet de police de paris
moi j'ose dire qu'on a un vrai problème
avec le préfet de police de paris
le préfet l'allemand aujourd'hui qui
depuis des mois n'assure pas la sérénité
et l'ordre public comme on pourrait le
souhaiter
dans la ville capitale qu'est paris et
puis il faut que nous protégions nos
forces de l'ordre y compris en leur
assurant des moyens et des formations
plus solide encore vous savez c'est un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui nos forces de
l'ordre en des formations obligatoires
on sait que à peine 40% et forces de
l'ordre au sont aujourd'hui en mesure
d'assumer toute leur formation
obligatoire notamment les formations aux
tirs pas parce qu'ils ne le veulent pas
mais tout simplement parce que l'état
le ministère n'est pas capable de
mobiliser les moyens nécessaires pour
leur assurer cette formation là il faut
donc que nous permettions à nos
policiers
cette formation complète qui leur
assurent aussi leur propre sécurité que
nous leur donnions des moyens vous le
voyez à l'occasion de plusieurs
reportages c'est insupportable
d'imaginer que certaines nos policiers
soit aujourd'hui obligés de financer
eux-mêmes personnellement leur propre
équipement
enfin nous sommes dans un grand pays qui
doit donner à nos forces de l'ordre tous
les moyens de se protéger et la question
budgétaire est donc une question
essentielle
nous sommes aujourd'hui à un moment où
nous avons plus que jamais besoin de nos
forces de l'ordre sur la question du
maintien de l'ordre public
mais sur les questions aussi de la
menace terroriste jamais nos policiers
et nos gendarmes ont été aussi mobilisés
qu'aujourd'hui il faut donc que l'état
soit à la hauteur de la situation
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
l'état bricole et qui n'est pas du tout
à la hauteur de la situation
j'insiste sur ce point mais ça devient
insupportable d'avoir des responsables
politiques des ministres un ministre de
l'intérieur qui fait des déclarations
d'amour aux forces de l'ordre toute la
journée et qui n'est pas capable de le
reproduire un seul acte pas un seul acte
regardez sur l'article 24 le ministre
darmanin a promis de protéger les forces
de l'ordre avec l'article 24 et au final
il n'y aura plus d'articles 24 plus
aucune disposition tels qu'il les avait
imaginées voyez bien que l'écart monstre
il y a entre les paroles les
déclarations de coke de gérald darmanin
et les actes qui sont des actes faible
jean-michel de vichy dans une question
sur les réflexions à tirer de cette
crise que traversent les forces de
l'ordre
aujourd'hui on vient d'en parler mais je
vais insister parce que c'est un point
qui évidemment est tout à fait capital
s'installe dans le pays une forme de
d'injonctions à devoir choisir un camp
contre notre fonds devrait choisir où le
camp des forces de l'ordre ou le camp
des citoyens je mets à part les
manifestants qui ne sont pas des
manifestants qui sont des casseurs et
sur ce sujet là nous devons être d'une
fermeté absolue
je pose une question simple lorsqu'il ya
eu les les bavures de policiers qui ont
tabassé un citoyen il ya quelques jours
immédiatement les policiers ont été
incarcérés qu en est il des manifestants
qui ont tapé du flic pendant les
manifestations
est-ce qu'ils ont été incarcérés non ils
n'ont pas été incarcérés et voyez bien
que ce deux poids deux mesures il est
devenu insupportable et autant je suis
parce que je suis républicain parce que
nous sommes républicains
nous devons être totalement exigeant et
intransigeant avec nos forces de l'ordre
parce qu'elle représente la république
et elles ne doivent pas déraper mais il
faut aussi que nous soyons absolument
intransigeant avec celles et ceux qui ne
sont plus des citoyens qui sont des
délinquants
lorsqu'ils s'en prennent aux forces de
l'ordre et aujourd'hui l'écart entre ces
deux mesures est devenu un écart
insupportable et puis je vous pose une
question où est le ministre de la
justice
où est le garde des sceaux ou et eric
dupond moretti
voilà des semaines qu'il est planqué
lorsqu'on est garde des sceaux on se
planque pas sur ces sujets le garde des
sceaux doit donner des instructions
politique pénale
il doit faire en sorte que ceux qui ont
dérapé d'un côté comme de l'autre
y compris les manifestants soient
sanctionnés et bien dupond moretti le
ministre dupont moretti qui jusqu'ici
n'étaient pas avares de montrer ses
grandes capacités oratoires et sa
capacité à avoir un avis sur tout et
bien sûr ce sujet n'a pas d'avis ça dit
bien le malaise profond qui est celui de
ce gouvernement
qui au fond n'est pas à l'aise avec
l'autorité de la république et
l'autorité de l'état
pierre de ménard tous les jours de
nouvelles dépenses publiques sont
annoncés et non financées le quoi qu'il
en coûte
déclarée par le président de la
république envoie l'économie de la
france dans le mur
comment réagissent les républicains
pierre a tout à fait raison c'était un
sujet absolument central vous rendez
compte que nous avons passé de longues
décennies dans notre pays a expliqué aux
français que la question de la dépense
publique était une question essentielle
et c'est une question essentielle est
depuis quelques jours les ministres se
succèdent sur les plateaux de télévision
en annonçant des plans qui relève de
milliard et 2 milliards
comment voulez vous que nous y
retrouvions comment voulez vous que la
parole publique soit crédible dans une
période comme celle ci et soyons clair
tous les moyens budgétaires qui doivent
être mobilisés pour sauver les
entreprises pour maintenir une économie
qui a besoin de redémarrer en urgence
tous ces moyens là doivent être
mobilisés parce que la casse économique
serait terrible et donc toutes les
mesures qui sont celles du chômage
partiel et mesures de soutien aux
entreprises l'est républicain nous avons
soutenu ces mesures là parce que notre
position n'est pas une position sectaire
qui consiste à aller contre l'intérêt du
pays en revanche nous devons dès
aujourd'hui nous poser la question de
l'assainissement de nos finances
publiques dans les décennies qui
viennent et je pense qu'il faut que tous
les républicains nous ayons un regard
courageux sur cette question de la dette
la vérité c'est que nous avons explosé
tous les plafonds d'endettement du pays
avec une dette qui est nouvelle parce
que cette dette elle est essentiellement
détenues par la banque centrale
européenne ce qui n'était pas le cas de
la dette que nous avons produite jusque
là et donc mon point de vue mais qui est
personnel vous posez la question j'ai
répondre c'est qu'il nous faut dissocier
ce qu'est la dette structurelle de notre
pays qui doit être réglé par des mesures
courageuses
celle que l'on empile depuis
des décennies de cette dette duco vide
qui doit être annonçant ce traité
différemment
comment je ne sais pas mais je pense que
ça mérite que nous posions la question
sereinement calmement avec nos
partenaires européens de ce que nous
ferons de cette date là parce que soyons
clairs cette dette là elle ne pourra pas
être financée par la fiscalité
c'est impossible si nous le faisons nous
planterons notre économie pour longues
années et c'est d'ailleurs une erreur
qui a pu être fait lors des précédentes
sorties de crise qui ne nous faut pas
refaire aujourd'hui
quant au gouvernement qui nous explique
que cette dette elle sera épongée de
manière quasi magique par une croissance
que nous retrouver lyon c'est une
hypothèse à laquelle personne ne croit
il nous faudra tellement de temps pour
retrouver une croissance que nous ne
pourrons pas épongé mécaniquement par le
seul effet de la croissance
cette date là et donc il y à des
réflexions qu'il nous faut lancer sur
une dette perpétuelle
mais ces réflexions la dont je ne
prétends pas détenir la vérité
elles ne peuvent être lancés qu'à un
niveau européen et nous avons une chance
dans la malchance c'est que tous les
pays européens sont peu ou prou dans la
même situation je ne parle pas de
l'endettement passé je parle de
l'endettement sur la période qu'ovide et
donc nous devrions pouvoir mettre autour
de la table tous nos partenaires
européens et pour ça il faut avoir un
leadership politique et c'est pas le cas
les manuels macron la réalité c'est
qu'il fait pardon de vous le dire
souvent le malin avec ses partenaires
européens et les partenaires mondiaux
mais ils sont pas nombreux à le prendre
au sérieux
et là où nicolas sarkozy était capable
de discuter solidement avec les
partenaires européens notamment au moins
de la dernière gestion de crise de 2008
emmanuel macron en est incapable si nous
avions un président de la république
capable de parler à tous les partenaires
européens d'être solide face aux
partenaires européens
il aurait déjà mis cette question sur la
table des discussions européennes et ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
mais cette question de la dette est une
question éminemment politique que de
toute façon nous devrons nous poser dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent la
conviction profonde c'est que la
situation est tellement inédite que les
solutions nous devons proposer seront
aussi inédite
on ne pourra pas régler
une situation aussi exceptionnel avec
des mesures habituelles
je pense que ce sera le moment de faire
preuve à la fois de courage politique
mais aussi de volontarisme et
d'imagination politique
nathalie du plessis robinson pose la
question sur la crise du coronavirus qui
a aggravé la situation économique de la
france
comment faire pour les dépenses
publiques nécessaires pour soutenir les
français ne soient pas la date de demain
il n'en parlait et je vais insister en
dissociant bien deux choses la dépense
publique de la dette quasi structurelle
du pays et de la dette liée à la crise
covin à se parler franchement nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui de mobiliser tous les
moyens pour que notre économie ne
disparaissent pas mais la meilleure
manière de relancer notre économie c'est
non seulement d'avoir les mesures
courageuses budgétaire le chômage
partiel je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
mais c'est aussi de permettre à cette
économie de redémarrer la meilleure
manière de faire en sorte que nous
n'ayons pas à récupérer à la petite
cuillère tous nos restaurateurs qui
forme un tissu de maillage économique
majeure en première ligne mais aussi
avec tous leurs sous traitants
la meilleure manière de ne pas les tuer
c'est de leur permettre de retrouver une
activité économique pour rendre compte
qu'on est en train de tuer une économie
qui ne demande qu'une chose c'est à
repartir et le restaurateur en sont
l'incarnation
voilà pourquoi chez les républicains
nous nous battons depuis des semaines
pour que nos restaurateurs puissent
retrouver une activité économique et
nous le faisons en responsabilité parce
que nous pensons qu'il est possible de
concilier le respect des mesures
sanitaires et la sauvegarde économique
il savait dans deux trois ans dans
quelques mois lorsque nous nous
réveillerons en sortie de crise
sanitaire
la crise économique et la crise sociale
qui nous attend j'ose le dire seront
d'autant plus grave bien plus supérieur
à la crise sanitaire que nous avons pu
connaître aujourd'hui et donc on ne peut
pas nous demander de tuer l'économie au
seul bénéfice du sanitaire il nous faut
trouver des moyens de concilier les deux
mesures et c'est notamment ce qui a
fondé le combat les républicains pour
réouvrir les petits commerces et nous
avons obtenu gain de cause notamment
grâce à la mobilisation des
députés et des sénateurs républicains
mais aussi parce que depuis des semaines
nous battons pour que les restaurateurs
puisse réouvrir jusqu'ici le
gouvernement ne nous a pas entendus et
je peux vous dire que c'est une affaire
que nous ne lâchons pas et c'est une
mobilisation que nous perdons pas de vue
bernadette de toulouse me pose la
question suivante par idéologie le
ministre de l'environnement fait des
choix énergétiques aberrant au risque de
coupure d'électricité comment expliquez
vous cela c'est une excellente question
il ya quelques mois à l'époque barbara
pompili n'était pas encore ministre a
été député et un de nos collègues
députés de l'est républicain raphaël
chaume berger qui le député de la
circonscription de fessenheim
débattez avec barbara pompili alors
député en lui disant que la fermeture
des deux réacteurs de fessenheim
les deux réacteurs nucléaires risque et
dans la précipitation d'entraîner des
coupures d'électricité à l'époque
barbara pompili qui n'était pas encore
ministre se marrer en expliquant qu'il
n'y avait aucune raison nous ayons des
coupures d'électricité que tout ça
c'était un fantasme
puis à quelques jours la même barbara
pompili mais cette fois-ci ministre se
présente à la télévision explique
presque banalement que nous risquons des
coupures d'électricité alors elle met
cela sur le dos de la crise sanitaire
alors que le sujet est totalement
déconnecté la vérité est simple parce
que ce gouvernement par des choix
idéologiques aime préparer et précipité
a voulu fermer les deux réacteurs
nucléaire de fessenheim en même temps
alors même qu'ils étaient alertés sur le
fait que cela nous poserait des
problèmes dans la sécurité
d'alimentation électrique du pays
ils ont voulu le faire pour des raisons
purement électorales eh bien ils ont mis
aujourd'hui en danger la sécurité
électrique du pays
c'est aussi simple que ça on est content
que nous sommes en 2020 en train de dire
que notre pays peut connaître des
coupures massives d'électricité assez
inouï et voyez bien à quel point les les
écologistes
au pouvoir parce que ma part à pompe ils
y ont fait partie nous amène vers une
régression totale des coupures
d'électricité massive
c'est pas seulement un problème pour
vous et moi dans notre confort personnel
et quotidien c'est un problème pour
l'économie de notre pays
ça veut dire qu'il va falloir négocier
avec les entreprises des plans de
réduction de consommation électrique et
donc mettre en danger la production
industrielle que nous avons encore dans
notre pays c'est une folie absolue et
c'est sûrement une bonne manière
d'illustrer l'hypocrisie de ces pseudo
écologistes qui n'en sont pas j'ajoute
que la fermeture des deux réacteurs
nucléaire de fessenheim a engendré la
réactivation de centrales à charbon pour
continuer à produire de l'électricité
vous voyez la folie on nous a expliqué
que pour des raisons de préservation de
l'environnement ont fermé deux réacteurs
nucléaires ceux de fessenheim qui ne
contribue pas à la pollution
atmosphérique et dans le même temps pour
compenser cette hypocrisie et cet
affichage on a relancé la production de
centrales à charbon qui elles produisent
une pollution significative sur
l'atmosphère et sur l'air que nous
respirons
bref vous voyez à quel point nous
nageons en pleine hypocrisie
notre collègue raphaël berger l'a
beaucoup dénoncé la raison de le faire
et c'est sûrement une manière de montrer
à quel point la vision que e.on de
l'écologie vision punitive régressive
n'a rien à voir avec la vision positive
et progressive de l'écologie que nous
voulons porter antonin de
divonne-les-bains me pose la question
suivante
je sais que votre action dans la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes a
été importante
pensez vous que la justice soit
suffisamment efficaces pour protéger les
victimes
celles ci souffrent souvent de délais de
procédures trop long antonin a tout à
fait raison
notre famille politique peut être fier
depuis nombreuses années d'avoir porté
un beau combat un combat noble qui suit
la protection des femmes victimes de
violences c'était simone veil
avec la loi sur livret les vg qui à
l'époque était portée pour protéger les
femmes si ensemble de mesures qui ont
été portées par des gouvernements
successibles dont celui de françois
fillon sous nicolas sarkozy
avec l'instauration des ordonnances de
protection qui permettait de protéger
les femmes dans un délai réduit
et puis c'est la loi que nous avons fait
voter au 1er janvier de l'année dernière
une loi portée par les républicains à
l'assemblée nationale et qui a été voté
à l'unanimité
j'étais fier de porter au nom de notre
famille politique et qui a permis de
marquer des avancées extrêmement fortes
pour protéger les femmes la première de
ces avancées c'est la généralisation du
bracelet anti rapprochement ça et ce
bracelet anti rapprochement
il permet d'éviter qu'un homme violent
ne s'approche trop d'une femme qui
pourrait être une victime c'est un outil
qui existe dans d'autres pays d'europe
notamment à l'espagne et qui est un
outil qui a fait ses preuves et
extrêmement efficace
notre loi a permis de généraliser le
bracelet anti rapprochement
on a accéléré notamment puisque vous me
posez la question les délais de
procédure en faisant en sorte qu'une
ordonnance de protection soient délivrés
en six jours maximum nous avons porté
des mesures pour suspendre l'autorité
parentale en considérant qu' un mari qui
bat sa femme ne peut pas être mon père
et donc nous avons développé toutes ces
mesures là et nous les avons inscrits
courageusement dans la loi sauf que
c'était au 1er janvier de cette année et
qu'il a fallu de longs mois au
gouvernement pour être capable de mettre
en place la loi que nous avions porté si
nous nous avons été à la hauteur le
gouvernement n'a pas été à la hauteur et
j'ose le dire je vais être précis sur
les bras c'est anti rapprochement au 1er
janvier de cette année il devait être
généralisée dans toutes les juridictions
du pays
il a fallu attendre le mois de juin au
mois de juin
nicole belloubet nous a dit que
finalement il fallait attendre le mois
de septembre
et puis au mois de septembre le ministre
la justice actuelle nous a dit que
finalement on testerait le bracelet dans
cinq juridictions du pays
ce qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la loi
qui généralise et le brasser dans toutes
les juridictions de france n'est pas
appliquée que seulement cinq
juridictions en bénéficient et vous
savez tant qu'il y aura une seule
victime dans le pays nous n'aurons pas
le droit de nous satisfaire de ces
petits pas de ses formes de l'acheter ce
dont nous avons besoin c'est d' acte
extrêmement courageux sur cette question
nous avons porté une loi forte et
j'appelle de mes voeux que nous allions
plus loin notamment avec des
juridictions spécialisées qui permettent
de protéger ces femmes chaque année le
nombre de féminicide explose
si tu as honte pour un pays comme le
nôtre et sur des sujets comme cela je
pense que notre famille politique
les républicains nous avons des valeurs
qui correspondent à la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes des valeurs
de détermination de courage et de
protection des plus fragiles des valeurs
de sanction de ceux qui ne méritent pas
notre compassion je parle des hommes
violent bref tout ça correspond à un des
beaux combats que nous pouvons mener
c'est vrai depuis de nombreuses années
c'est vrai depuis quelques temps et il
nous faudra aller encore plus loin
je passe à des questions qui sortent un
peu de de l'actualité et c'est pascal de
provins belle comme une province qui me
pose la question suivante que
proposez-vous de concret pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux
cette crise sanitaire aura illustré
l'abandon des territoires pascal a tout
à fait raison député du lot dans mon
département c'est un sujet majeur que
celui de la désertification médicale et
pas de recette miracle je crois pas aux
outils qui imposerait à des médecins
d'aller dans tel ou tel territoire et
c'est un député du lot rural qui vous le
dit je pense qu'il faut que nous
attirions avec des mesures incitatives
nos médecins à venir dans nos
territoires mais au delà il nous faut
totalement repensé l'hôpital cette crise
là elle allait montrer à quel point les
mégastructures la concentration des
soins hospitaliers dans des
établissements de plus en plus grand de
plus en plus parfois déconnectés ne nous
avait pas aidés il ya une erreur
collective qui a été commise depuis de
nombreuses années
c'est cette idée au fond que plus c'est
gros plus c'est thébaux notamment en
matière sanitaire
il fallait à outrance mutualiser les
moyens moi je pense que il nous faut
retravailler sur des structures
hospitalières de proximité sur des
structures de soins de proximité
notamment en s'appuyant sur les maisons
de santé maisons médicales qui
aujourd'hui my de manière assez
massivement territoires ruraux faire en
sorte que dans ces maisons de santé on
puisse avoir notamment des soins
d'urgence sur de la cardiologie
comment faire en sorte que lorsque vous
êtes victime d'une alerte cardiaque de
narry cardiaque d'un avc vous puissiez
être prise en charge au plus près de
chez vous dans des petites structures
qu'ils soient spécialisés sur ces
urgences les plus quotidiennes pour
éviter y compris d'engorger les urgences
hospitalières
ces outils là ils sont développés dans
certains territoires ruraux et pour ça
il faut avoir une vraie vision
décentralisée je pense qu'il faut mettre
fin une bonne fois pour toutes à nos
agences régionales de santé
ces outils technocratie dans lesquelles
nous avons tous baigné
une manière ou d'une autre mais qui ont
démontré à quel point il ne permettait
pas l'efficacité l'agilité en période de
crise sont des machines à fabriquer de
la léthargie sont des machines à
fabriquer de la lenteur à diluer la
responsabilité et la décision politique
est donc un peu de courage consisterait
à mettre un grand pied coups de pied
dans la fourmilière et à dégager ces
moyens qui sont des moyens
administratifs pour les opérationnels
sanitaires sont nos médecins nos
professionnels libéraux et nos
professionnels hospitaliers qui vaut
bien le dire manque terriblement de
moyens aujourd'hui l'administration de
la santé est bien mieux dotés que les
opérationnels de la santé et ça c'est
une vraie mesure que notre famille
politique peut porter font de dire la
question c'est pas plus ou moins de
fonctionnaires la question c'est mieux
de fonctionnaires comment à l'hôpital
nous transférons des moyens de
l'administration qui a son rôle à jouer
mais qui est devenue pléthorique
aujourd'hui vers les opérationnels c'est
à dire ce dont nous avons besoin en
particulier dans une gestion de crise
comme celle que nous venons de connaître
jean-luc d'avon au lendemain de la crise
et j'ai les jeunes nous vivons une crise
sans précédent
avez vous conscience des graves
conséquences économiques et sociales à
venir
jean-luc jamais totalement conscience et
conséquences économiques je les ai
évoqué tout à l'heure notamment pour nos
restaurateurs qui m'inquiète beaucoup
et les conséquences sociales elle
m'inquiète bien plus encore que la crise
sanitaire et je vais insister sur sur
cette question là un chiffre simple nous
sommes aujourd'hui à près de 8 millions
de nos concitoyens m'entendais 8
millions de nos concitoyens dont on sait
qu'ils n'ont pas un accès
normal à l'alimentation nous avons sur
ces 8 millions de nos concitoyens plus
de 6 millions de français qui ont besoin
de l'aide alimentaire pour se nourrir
ces six millions de personnes qui n'ont
pas à manger dans notre pays aujourd'hui
ont été produits en large partie par la
crise sanitaire et la responsabilité
politique qui va être la note dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent va
consister à gérer cette vague de misère
et de pauvreté à laquelle notre pays va
être confronté et je pense que notre
famille politique a une parole forte à
porter savez si nous sommes les uns les
autres engagés en politique c'est parce
que nous pensons que nos plus grands et
nos plus beaux devoir c'est de lutter
contre les injustices de lutter contre
eux ce qui est une forme de fatalité de
la vie et cette crise sanitaire elle va
fabriquer des injustices insupportables
des fatalités est insupportable et nous
ne parlons pas là de femmes et d'hommes
qui ne voudrait pas travailler de femmes
et d'hommes qui auraient choisi leur
situation non nous ne parlons de femmes
et d'hommes qui vont être frappés de
plein fouet par une crise qui n'ont pas
voulu par un arrêt d'activité qui n'ont
pas souhaité et chivu risque de basculer
dans la misère
notre famille politique elle a quelque
chose à dire sur ce sujet elle l'a
toujours fait sur des grandes causes est
une des causes qui nous a rendu le plus
fier à droite c'est celle du samu social
de paris
grande et belle époque où jacques chirac
et xavier emmanuelli porte un immense et
magnifique combat qui est celui des sans
abri et du samu social de paris
mais ça c'est la droite c'est la droite
républicaine
lorsque jean louis borloo et christine
lagarde porte un beau combat sur la
protection du surendettement pour nos
concitoyens
c'est notre famille politique qui fait
progresser les choses j'ai que vous
croyez comme moi ont une droite qui est
capable de protéger celles et ceux qui
sont les plus fragiles qui en ont besoin
parce que la vie est parfois difficile
qu'on n'a pas toujours mériter ce qui
nous arrive et qu'on doit être capable
de faire une distinction entre ceux qui
ne font pas d'efforts et qui doivent en
faire davantage et ceux qui malgré leurs
efforts ont besoin qu'on leur tende la
main
c'est aussi ça ce qui rend notre famille
politique fier des belles valeurs
humanistes qui
qui sont les siennes hubert de talence
nous pose une question sur la politique
du handicap a mené par les républicains
là encore hubert voilà une des uns des
grands et beaux combats qu'une famille
politique a toujours porté les plus les
lois les plus fortes en matière de
handicap ont été portées par la droite
républicaine
les plus emblématiques sont les lois de
2005 porté par jacques chirac qui ont
transformé la politique du handicap dans
notre pays la première convention que
notre président christian jacob a voulu
que nous tenions ici aux républicains
c'était une convention sur le handicap
et beaucoup d'observateurs dont on
disait au fond les républicains vous
n'avez rien à dire sur le handicap et
bien d'autres premières conventions et
ce choix là je le salue la part de
christian jacob
c'était le choix de renouer avec cette
tradition qui est celle de notre famille
politique de tendre la main envers celui
qui a peut-être le moins de chance et
qui a toute sa place dans notre société
et je vous invite à aller voir sur le
site des républicains la série de trente
propositions nous avions porté sur le
handicap pour mieux intégrer les enfants
en situation de handicap à l'école pour
mieux les intégrer dans l'emploi et pour
avoir une politique efficace ces
propositions sont les toutes premières
que nous avions faite au sein des
républicains elles sont à votre
disposition et c'est un vrai projet
politique est un vrai beau projet de
société que la droite républicaine doit
pouvoir porter gérard de lyon me demande
ce que je pense de la démocratie
participative notamment au niveau local
gens pensent du bien j'ai un peu de mal
avec l'expression parce que c'est
l'expression de ségolène royal tout ce
qui vient de la gauche a tendance
parfois blesser un peu pantois
mais le sujet est important je pense
qu'on peut tous être d'accord sur le
fait que notre pays traverse une crise
qui est aussi une crise démocratique et
le lien qui s'est distendu entre les
décideurs politiques les responsables
politiques les représentants politiques
et des citoyens est un problème alors on
pourrait dire au fond c'est pas grave il
faut s'y faire c'est comme ça avoir une
forme de vision fataliste
moi je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
que nos belles et grandes institutions
de la vème république
sont un héritage magnifique et que dans
le cas de ces institutions qui nous faut
préserver parce que nous sommes des
gaullistes et que ces institutions nous
ont permis une stabilité
on doit pouvoir imaginer des outils
nouveaux qui permettent de recréer un
lien entre les représentants les
citoyens moi je crois en la démocratie
représentative
je ne crois pas que les citoyens
puissent en permanence être consulté sur
tout et n'importe quoi mais je crois que
sur certains vrais sujets ils peuvent
être consultés je crois au référendum
utilisé avec force au respect de la
décision rendue par les citoyens lors
d'un référendum
on n'a pas toujours fait je pense que si
demain nous voulons réhabiliter la
parole publique il faut que la parole du
citoyen consultés par référendum soient
respectés y compris au niveau local je
pense aussi que pour conforter la
démocratie représentative
il faut que nous les députés nous
puissions avoir un lien encore plus
direct avec les citoyens avec nous nous
sommes deux députés ancré dans les
territoires ddt un peu l'adn de notre
famille politique c'est beaucoup moins
le cas des députés de la république en
marche qui souvent ignorent qu'ils sont
élus de territoire et de ses conceptions
qu'il découvre de temps en temps mais je
vous fais une proposition vous savez
sûrement que deux fois par an les
députés maîtrise l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale avec
majoritairement c'est le gouvernement
qui dit quels sont les textes qui vont
être débattues au parlement et à
l'assemblée nationale singulièrement
puisque nous n'avons pas la majorité
mais deux fois par an ce sont les
députés de chaque groupe politique
qu'ils ont ce qu'on appelle des niches
parlementaires qui permettent d'imposer
pendant une journée que les textes
soient débattues de moi l'idée selon
laquelle on puisse y en avoir plusieurs
fois par an des niches citoyenne qui
fasse qu'à partir de quelques centaines
de milliers de signatures les citoyens
puissent nous demandez nous
parlementaires de nous emparer d'un
sujet de le débattre à l'assemblée
nationale c'est une proposition qui
m'intéresse parce qu'elle permet de
sauvegarder la démocratie représentative
c'est aux citoyens de solliciter leurs
parlementaires pour qu'ils débattent
d'un sujet mais au final c'est aux
parlementaires qui sont élus les
représentants du peuple de trancher sont
pas aux citoyens de nous tenir la main
nous rendons des comptes devant les
citoyens le moment venu mais nous
croyons en la démocratie représentative
bien cette solution qui permet de
recréer le lien entre les citoyens la
vie parlementaire et de préserver la
démocratie représentative qui pour moi a
du sens pour temporiser notre démocratie
c'est une proposition je formule et qui
peut faire partie des pistes à
travailler jean-pierre ecully du 69 me
dit qu'ils étaient impressionnés par les
60% de français qui ont boudé les urnes
aux dernières municipales jean bien
considérer la raison que c'est une
catastrophe pour notre démocratie
comment enrayer ce désintérêt des
français pour la politique a sûrement
déjà en faisant en sorte que la
politique permette de changer les choses
qu'est ce qui fait aujourd'hui de nos
concitoyens ne s'intéressent plus à la
politique
la tête parce que la politique n'est pas
si intéressante que ça il faut dire
aussi à quel point depuis nombreuses
années nous avons le sentiment que la
politique ne permet pas de changer les
choses et emmanuel macron est la
quintessence de cette incarnation de la
comédie permanente
macron c'est le matamore c'est celui qui
montre ses muscles et qui au final est
incapable d'agir mais il manquerait il
n'a aucune volonté de changer les choses
ni sur la mondialisation ni sur notre
développement économique ni sur les
injustices sociales
ça ne l'intéresse pas changé chose il
est là pour gérer la fatalité de notre
époque
eh bien je pense que la politique et
intéressera nos concitoyens si elle est
capable comme par le passé comme sous
volontarisme de nicolas sarkozy comme
sous la force du général de gaulle la
volonté de jacques chirac lors de son
premier mandat en particulier de
démontrer qu'elle est capable d'avoir
une prise sur la réalité qu'elle est
capable de transformer le quotidien des
français sylla à partir de là que la
politique retrouvera son crédit et puis
il faut que la politique
pardon d'être un peu utopiste retrouve
aussi un goût pour les idéaux
moi je m'épuise de voir les techno qui
font de la politique aujourd'hui je vais
puisse devoir des députés qui n'ont plus
aucun idéal qui ne rêve plus de rien qui
tous les jours n'ont en tête que des
tableaux excel qui nous explique que ce
sujet on peut pas le traiter parce que
c'est trop compliqué
que l'on peut pas parce que bercy a dit
qu'on ne pouvait pas le faire parce que
tel rapport de bons techno pardon de
vous le dire comme je le pense a
expliqué qu'il fallait surtout pas
toucher à ce sujet et moi je crois que
la politique elle retrouvera le coeur
des français si elle est capable de
porter un idéal si on est capable
d'avoir un politique des combattants qui
sur des sujets le handicap les violences
conjugales nous en parlions la misère la
pauvreté se lève en disant tant que nous
n'aurons pas réglé ce problème nous ne
dormirons pas tranquille ce qui a rendu
la politique noble pendant deux
décennies et c'est ce qui je crois peut
aussi renouer le lien entre les citoyens
et leurs représentants politiques
moi j'espère puissions retrouver la
force du politique ça vous paraît
sûrement un peu théorique et un peu
lyrique ce que je vous dis mais je le
pense vraiment je pense que jour la
politique portera un idéal à nouveau
alors je pense qu'elle retrouvera le
coeur et le chemin de nos concitoyens
henri de draguignan me demande si je
suis favorable à une juridiction
d'exception pour les auteurs de crimes
terroristes notamment henry je n'aime
pas l'expression de juridiction
d'exception parce que je suis un
républicain je crois en la justice de la
république et je crois pas que la
justice de la république ait besoin
d'exception je pense qu'elle a besoin
d'être ferme
solide sur ses principes et ça c'est un
vrai sujet un chantier colossal
en revanche ce à quoi je crois c'était
une cour de justice comme il en existe
déjà aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sortent pas
du cadre républicain puisque ce qui
donnera notre force ce qui nous
permettra de garder notre force c'est
notre cas dans républicain mais une cour
de sûreté de la république qui
permettrait de frapper plus vite et plus
fort ce qui nous menace et notamment les
la menace terroriste à laquelle nous
avons à faire face aujourd'hui et avec
notre début notre collègue député
olivier marc l'ex il ya un travail qui
est engagée au sein des républicains
pour réfléchir à une proposition de cour
de sûreté de la république qui ne soit
pas une juridiction d'exception qui soit
une juridiction dans le cadre
républicain qui est le nôtre qui fait
notre honneur et notre force mais qui
permettent notamment d'expulser le plus
rapidement possible sans tourner autour
du pot celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont des menaces claires pour la
sécurité de la république
au fond on peut pas imaginer une seule
seconde que nous n'ayons plus les moyens
judiciaires républicain d'expulser
celles et ceux qui sont fichés dans des
fichiers dont on sait que vous n'y êtes
pas par hasard et que si vous y êtes
c'est que vous comporter une menace pour
la république et donc ces mesures
d'expulsion je considère qu'on doit les
mettre en oeuvre avec beaucoup plus
d'efficacité aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
elles ne sont pas mises en oeuvre et
qu'il faut pour cela respecter le cadre
républicain
mais trouver des outils plus efficaces
et une cour de justice une cour de
sûreté de la république pardon serait
une mesure intéressante nous sommes en
train d'y travailler et nous ferons dans
les semaines qui viennent des
propositions
vous voyez sur tous ces sujets ce qui
anime les républicains c'était un devoir
de responsabilité
nous ne sommes pas l'extrême droite et
nous ne dériverons jamais nous aurons
toujours un discours qui est un discours
républicain - les idées folles de
l'extrême droite qui piétine nos
principes tout nos principes
républicains je n'en veux pas je pense
que c'est dans le respect des principes
républicains que nous pouvons nous la
droite républicaine être responsable et
efficace une cour de sûreté de la
république c'est une proposition qui
permet de concilier le respect des
valeurs républicaines auxquelles nous
sommes attachés qui fait nous n'avons
rien à voir avec les apprentis sorciers
de l'extrême droite et qui permet aussi
de répondre à l'urgence sécuritaire de
notre pays je pense que c'est là que les
français nous attendent sur un discours
ferme mais un discours responsable marie
chantal du cap d'agde me demande si je
plaide pour une augmentation des petites
retraites
non seulement nous plaidons pour une
augmentation des petites retraites mais
nous nous sommes battus et nous avons
obtenu des résultats
je pense notamment à celles qui étaient
les plus petites tensions qui des
pensions agricoles et de ce point de vue
les républicains nous nous sommes
engagés avec d'autres de nos collègues
qui ne sont pas notre famille politique
pour mener cette bataille là force est
de constater que nous avons réussi à
faire voter la loi mais que le
gouvernement n'a toujours pas mis en
oeuvre les dispositions de la loi pour
revaloriser les parmi les plus petites
retraites qui sont les retraites
agricoles au delà ça me permet de vous
dire un mot la question de la réforme
des retraites ce n'est que mon avis
personnel je pense que c'est pas du tout
le moment pour réouvrir ce dossier de la
réforme des retraites je pense qu'il
nous faut du temps pour sereinement
construire un projet qui soit pas le
bricolage auquel le gouvernement nous
avait préparé il ya quelques mois il
nous faudra réformer notre système des
retraites il nous faudra le faire avec
courage mais il nous faudra le faire
avec justice on ne mène pas une réforme
des retraites sans justice sociale et on
le fera encore moins dans la période de
grande crise sociale que nous allons
connaître et c'est le moment pour les
républicains d'être au rendez vous
d'ailleurs nous l'avons fait puisque
nous avions à l'époque fait des
propositions très sérieuses sur la
question de la réforme des retraites
pour concilier l'exigence de maîtrise
budgétaire de contrôle de nos dépenses
publiques et de justice sociale et
notamment en faisant de la pénibilité le
coeur du dispositif pour la question de
l'âge de départ à la retraite
mes yeux n'est pas le principal sujet
parce que selon le métier que vous avez
exercé vous souffrirez plus ou moins de
partir tôt ou tard en retraite
lorsque vous avez été maçon pour ne
prendre que cet exemple mais il y en a
bien d'autres que vous avez passé 30 ans
à soulever des charges a travaillé par
tout le temps mais il est évident que
votre âge de départ à la retraite
il doit pouvoir être anticipé parce que
vous vous aurez plus souffert
physiquement de votre travail et la
proposition nous avions faite consistait
à dire que au fur et à mesure qu'on
travaille dans une situation pénible ont
gagné une année de départ anticipé à la
retraite
ça c'est une me
de justice sociale trois ans de travail
en pénibilité un an de départ en
retraite
gagné voilà une des mesures nous avions
porté avec la mesure courageuse qui est
celle de l'allongement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite parce que nous ne
pourrons pas faire autrement mais tant
que la mesure de pénibilité et là on
assure la mesure de justice sociale
voyez sur tous ces sujets nous y avons
travaillé au fond je suis pas très loin
de penser que si les français nous le
faisait à nouveau confiance nous serions
bien plus capable qu'emmanuel macron de
porter de vraies réformes pour le pays y
compris sur la question de la réforme
des retraites jean-claude d'orsay me
demande ce que je pense de la gestion de
la crise sanitaire du gouvernement
est-ce qu'elle a été satisfaisante ici
elle ne l'a pas été pour quoi nous
aurions nous les républicains sûrement
ont fait mieux à leur place cette
gestion de la crise sanitaire a été une
calamité
je pèse mes mots en le disant première
calamité c'est le mensonge ne pouvait
pas gérer une crise sanitaire en
commençant par un bobard est le premier
de ces bobards ça a été celui des
masques un bobard éhontée lorsque la
porte parole du gouvernement où vous en
souvenez à l'époque si bête ndiaye
lorsque le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand lorsque le premier
ministre de l'époque edouard philippe
nous expliquer la main sur le coeur
qu'il ne fallait surtout pas porter le
masque que ça ne servait à rien et que
peut-être même c'était dangereux
à cette époque là ils ont répété des
jours durant qu'il ne fallait pas porter
de masque
comment voulez vous que ceux qui ont
expliqué aux français que les masques
étaient presque dangereux quelques mois
après peuvent expliquer aux français
qu'il faut obligatoirement porter des
masques et font lorsque vous commencez
la gestion d'une crise sanitaire qui est
une crise de qui nécessite la confiance
sur un mensonge aussi éhontée
vous ne pouvez pas réussir lorsque le
ministre de la santé à la sortie de la
première vague nous explique que nous
serons prêts pour la seconde vague et
qu'il nous dit notamment qu'il s'engage
à ouvrir 14 min
une réanimation supplémentaires
aujourd'hui nous avons à peine une
centaine de lits de réanimation
supplémentaires cet engagement c'est lui
qui l'a pris il a été incapable de le
tenir sur la question des tests on nous
avait promis des tests massif efficaces
rapides les premières semaines ont été
calamiteuses
il a fallu parfois dix jours pour
obtenir le résultat d'un test ce qui ne
sert plus absolument à rien bref sur
tous ces sujets le gouvernement a menti
et a été incapable de gérer la situation
alors peut-être que je ne devrais pas le
dire parce que ce que j l'âge c'est à
mon avis ce que pensent beaucoup de
français et que vient-on moment
lorsqu'on veut être à la hauteur d'une
situation on ne peut pas mentir en
permanence à nos concitoyens
je passe sur la situation nous
connaissons aujourd'hui où la
technocratie a pris le pouvoir sur la
gestion notre quotidien avec des
situations dont on croirait qu'elles
sont des blagues
lorsque premier ministre parle du
premier ministre de la france pas le
sous-secrétaire d'état aux choux farcis
ou aux remontées mécaniques
je parle du premier ministre de la
république française vient nous
expliquer que les stations de ski seront
finalement ouverte mais que les
remontées mécaniques seront fermés je
vous assure que à cet instant je me suis
demandé si c'était une blague
s'il était incapable de comprendre ce
qu'il disait aussi nous prenez pour des
idiots et voyez l'accumulation tout ça
ça peut nous faire sourire mais c'est
d'une gravité absolue parce que sur la
question des stations de ski précisément
ils sont en train d'abattre un pan
entier de notre économie
un pan entier et comme ils sont
incapables de gérer la situation
ils en sont la punition permanente des
français et donc l'imagination de la
technocratie est phénoménal on vous
explique que vous pouvez vous entassés
dans des métros mais que vous ne pouvez
pas aller au ski au grand air on vous
explique que vous pouvez vous entassés
dans des métros dans des bus mais qui en
revanche si vous avez le malheur de
partir au ski à l'étranger lorsque vous
reviendrez
on vous mettra en quarantaine on vous
punira on est incapable de fermer nos
frontières
en période de menace terroriste par
contre on est capable de punir d'en
fermer certaines nos concitoyens en
confinement
parce qu'ils auront une malheur d'aller
en suisse ou dans les pays limitrophes
enfin pardon nous le dira mais on est
chez les fous il y a une chose que je
veux vous dire très sérieusement qui
n'est pas facile à dire mais que je
pense profondément
nous sommes en train de nous habituer à
une privation de liberté qui je crois
est inquiétante
je sais que c'est pas simple à dire
parce que très vite on va me soupçonner
d'être irresponsable et de ne pas voir
la menace sanitaire
enfin qu'un même quand même depuis des
mois voyez bien à quel point
progressivement l'oxygène de nos
libertés est réduit et progressivement
je crains nous habitions à des
privations de liberté qui en vérité sont
insupportables et sûrement inacceptable
je prends un exemple simple lorsque le
président de la république dans son
adresse aux français dit au détour d'une
phrase que l'idée selon laquelle nous
pourrions contraindre à l' isolement des
malades est une idée à laquelle il nous
faut réfléchir mais moi je vous le dit
personnellement comme je le pense ça me
fait bondir
ça veut dire parce que l'idée que nous
puissions privé de liberté aux malades
sous contrainte comme on le fait pour un
délinquant
ça me pose un problème de principe ça me
pose un problème idéologique et je pense
que nous sommes dans une période où la
tempête est tellement lourde tellement
grave qu'il ne nous faut pas perdre de
vue ce qui fonde nos principes et la
préservation des libertés
sa forme nos principes ça font des
principes de la france les principes de
la république
mais ça font aussi les principes de la
droite républicaine
michel de cergy pontoise le pose cette
question cette crise sanitaire aura fini
par achever la petite classe moyenne
comment lui venir en aide ce qui est
vrai c'est que toutes celles et ceux qui
travaillaient dur au quotidien dans
notre pays qui n'étaient pas les plus
privilégiés souvent accumulé des petits
boulots qui comptait pas leurs heures
sont ceux qui sont frappés le plus
durement par la crise sanitaire
je vous parle des restaurateurs tout à
l'heure nos petits restaurateurs qui
souvent on gage et tout ce qu'ils ont de
patrimoine personnel pour monter leur
entreprise vont se retrouver dans une
situation professionnelle désastreuse
mais aussi dans une situation
personnelle désastreuse et je pense
qu'il va nous falloir dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent réfléchira
dispositions qui permettent de protéger
le patrimoine personnel de celles et
ceux qui durant cette crise auront payé
les pots cassés les plus durs je
m'explique pour moi il y aurait rien de
plus injuste et insupportable que
restaurateur qu'on a empêchés de
travailler risque de sacrifier parce
qu'il est caution personnelle de son
entreprise
l'ensemble de ses économies et de son
patrimoine personnel ça je pense que ce
serait une injustice terrible et donc il
nous faut politiquement travailler y
compris avec les banques pour qu on
puisse isolé ponctuellement ce qui
relève de la crise sanitaire et ce qui
relève de l'erreur de gestion etc
offrons toutes celles et ceux qui vont
traverser une période très dure ne se
retrouve pas à genoux y compris
personnellement je pense que cette
question c'est une question que nous
devons poser est installé dans le débat
politique avec beaucoup d'autres mesures
notamment de mesures de réengagement
vers le travail ce qui permettrait aux
classes moyennes qui avaient une
activité professionnelle de sortir à
nouveau la tête de l'eau c'est de
retrouver une activité professionnelle
et pour ça il faut remettre le pays en
état de marche économique ce qui n'est
pour l'instant pas le cas
béatrice de paris m'interroge sur la
laïcité est un sujet de fractures de
notre société
ils me demandent que devons nous faire
mais après ça raison la laïcité ses skis
au fond de la république sait si aussi à
fonder parmi les plus beaux combats de
la droite républicaine
jacques chirac françois baroin à
l'époque chargé par jacques chirac de
travailler sur cette question avait
porté des propositions très forte
c'est le moment notamment où on interdit
le voile à l'école
ce débat qui avaient été installés débat
dans lequel la gauche qui pendant un
temps avait été en défense de la laïcité
c'est totalement fourvoyé et en est venu
à défendre l'indéfendable
ça c'est la sphère de la gauche pour ce
qui est de la droite nous devons être
intransigeants sur les questions de
laïcité
la laïcité c'est une chance pour notre
pays une chance pour la république la
laïcité c'est un terrain dans lequel
chacun peut s'émanciper
c'est un terrain commun c'est ce terrain
dans lequel juive catholique musulman
nous avons en commun quelque chose qui
s'appelle la république et les valeurs
de la république et moi je crois
profondément en ce terrain là je crois
profondément qu'il nous faut avoir
personnellement nos jardins individuel
et secret pour cultiver de croire ou de
ne pas croire de croire au dieu que nous
avons choisie mais il nous faut aussi
des temps où nous pouvons considérer que
nous avons une raison de vivre ensemble
je sais que tout ça paraît très galvaudé
et sa part est galvaudé parce que on a
affaibli tous les terrains de la laïcité
on a par lâcheté progressivement laisser
entrer des signes religieux des signes
de soumission le voile fait pour moi
partie des signes de soumission de la
femme
voilà pourquoi je combats le voile pas
seulement pour les questions pas pour
les questions religieuses
je combats le voile parce que je
considère que c'est un signe de
soumission des femmes et j'ose le dire
très franchement très librement
je pense d'ailleurs que tous les
féministes de ce pays celles et ceux qui
sont vraiment féministe n'aurait pas
supporté qu'une femme se voit soumise
par le voile à autre chose que ce
qu'elle aurait véritablement choisi à
son émancipation
ce que je dis là il ya encore quelques
grandes pensées de gauche qui le dit
je pense elisabeth badinter il ya aussi
quelques grandes pensées de droite qui
ose le dire bref la laïcité c'est ce
terrain nous devons reconquérir en
faisant sortir de nos écoles de nos
universités
tout ce qui relève du geste religieux et
moi j'irai plus loin je pense que dans
tout ce qui relève du service public
il ne devrait pas y avoir de présence de
signes religieux
je considère que lorsqu'on rentre dans
un lieu qui est un lieu de service
public on doit se défaire de ce qui fait
notre différence religieuse
je sais que c'est une proposition un peu
audacieuse sont nombreux à la partager
chez les républicains
je pense qu'il ne faut pas être timide
sur ce sujet on a passé des années à
perdre du terrain sur la laïcité et
quand on perd du terrain sur la laïcité
on perd du terrain sur ce qu'est la
république quelques questions sur notre
famille politique
rémy danger me demande comment faire
pour emmener républicaine plus attractif
auprès la jeunesse et plus généralement
comment faire pour que la jeunesse
s'intéresse davantage à la politique il
rémy nous y travaillons c'est une des
premières impulsions christian jacob a
voulu donner notamment en lançant le
grand rassemblement que nous avons au
port marly en septembre dernier notre
famille politique a été la seule famille
politique à être capable de réunir plus
de 1000 jeunes au port marly qui pendant
deux jours
venus de toute la france ont travaillé
sur les questions d'écologie sur les
questions d'économie sur les question
d'autorité de l'état de valeurs de la
république et je peux vous dire que
lorsque christian jacob nous a lancé ce
défi de réunir 1000 jeunes
en septembre dernier il y avait beaucoup
plus de cassandre pour nous expliquer
que nous n'y arrivions pas que de celles
et ceux qui pensaient que nous allions
relever le défi bien avec toutes nos
équipes nous avons relevé ce défi et
nous avons réuni 1000 jeunes là où
personne ne pensait que nous arriverions
et nous avons eu deux journées qui nous
ont redonné un espoir considérable en la
jeunesse de notre famille politique est
fort de cet épisode là de cet événement
du port marly qui a été pour nous un
événement fondateur christian jacob a
souhaité que nous répondions un
mouvement des jeunes républicains et
c'est le travail que nous venons
d'engager nous sommes en train de
finaliser
et je peux te dire rémy que au début de
l'année prochaine et dans les mois qui
suivront nous allons lancer une
refondation totale du mouvement des
jeunes républicains pour faire en sorte
que une équipe s'installe dans ce
mouvement qu'elle permette de lancer une
dynamique qui a existé pendant plusieurs
années il y aura une nouvelle élection
du président des jeunes république est
et de l'ensemble de son équipe l'année
prochaine et nous allons donner une
feuille de route autonome au mouvement
des jeunes c'est une des grandes
propositions de christian jacob de faire
en sorte que ce mouvement soit un
mouvement autonome et que ce mouvement
des jeunes puissent voler de ses propres
ailes
un important soutien aux républicains et
en s'adressant directement à la jeunesse
il faut que ce soit la jeunesse qui
parle à la jeunesse de notre pays et tu
as raison de dire que le défi il va au
delà des républicains le défi c'est un
défi national
l'idée selon laquelle notre famille
politique puisse se couper la jeunesse
de ce pays c'est une idée folle c'est
une idée folle aucun candidat à la
présidentielle aucun grand parti
politique n'a réussi à conquérir
l'élection présidentielle s'il n'a pas
conquis le coeur de la jeunesse c'était
vrai pour jacques chirac à 95 c'était
vrai pour nicolas sarkozy en 2007
et ça doit être vrai pour le candidat
qui portera nos couleurs demain nous
aurons dès l'année prochaine
réorganiser ce parti autour de notre
président pour faire en sorte que
notamment sur la question des jeunes
tous les outils soient prêts pour mener
une des mères des batailles qu'il
l'élection présidentielle michael de
montbazon me demande comment je peux
vous assurer que le programme des
républicains ne créera pas de contrainte
supplémentaire pour les entreprises et
les citoyens
cette présidence nous étouffe de mesures
restrictives je suis bien d'accord
c'est la fameuse phrase de georges
pompidou cc d'emmerder les français
pensent que c'est une des bonnes mesures
et pour le coup nous n'aurons pas de mal
à faire mieux qu'eux
les techno de castex et compagnie qui au
quotidien à mon avis se demande comment
rendre la vie des français encore plus
compliqué jeudi un peu sur le ton de la
boutade mais je voudrais plus sérieux
plus sérieux en vous disant que laisser
plus de liberté aux français c'est aussi
cultiver chez eux le sens de la
responsabilité
c'est ce qu'il ya de pire avec cette
série de mesures qui nous contraignent
au quotidien c'est qu'elle nous
infantilise est une société qui est
infantilisé au quotidien c'est une
société qui perd tout sens des
responsabilités
le projet pour liquider républicain doit
être celui de redonner plus de liberté
aux français et donc plus de
responsabilités voilà des valeurs qui
nous différencie à la fois de ski et la
macro ni de ce que son ski et ce
gouvernement et de ce que sont les
députés de la république en marche si
tenté qu'il y ait des convictions et est
une idéologie apporter nicolas de
toulouse me demande quel est le nôtre le
projet de notre famille politique
concernant l'élection régionale en
occitanie nicolas a raison de
s'intéresser à l'occitanie parce que
c'est une merveilleuse région
c'est ma région c'est une région dans
laquelle on forgent les caractères des
tempéraments et c'est une région dont on
oublie ce qui est de midi pyrénées du
moins que la droite a réussi à la
conquérir par le passé nous avons eu
avec
baudis grands présidents de région et
cette région nous avons su la conquérir
à une époque il n'y a pas de raison que
nous ne soyons pas capables de mener la
même conquête
peut-être que derrière la question de
nicolas il y à la question de savoir ce
que personnellement je ferai dans cette
élection régionale
pour être tout à fait honnête avec
nicolas il le sait sûrement je suis
profondément amoureux de cette région et
donc comme pour tous ceux qui sont
amoureux de la région j'ai un peu de mal
à me dire que je ne mènerait pas une
bataille en occitan est ce que je serai
le candidat pour mener la liste en
occitanie je ne le sais pas et je
prendrai la décision dans les tout
prochains jours
ce que je sais c'est que je
m'impliquerai personnellement dans cette
campagne je laisserai pas tomber les
copains d'abord je laisserai pas tomber
cette région et si ce n'est pas moi qui
mène cette campagne là aux côtés de
celle ou de celui qui la mènera je serai
extrêmement actif parce que je pense que
nous avons quelque chose à faire en
occitanie tôt ou tard nous aurons
quelque chose à faire dans cette belle
région qui ressemble au tempérament
notre famille politique
régis de poitiers me demande ce que je
pense de notre famille politique que du
bien il me demande si elle est prête
pour les élections régionales de 2021
au delà de vous dire que je pense que du
bien je vais vous dire que notre famille
politique et au travail alors je sais
que ça ça ça fait pas la une des
journaux ça fait pas la une des médias
parce que d'abord vous savez qu'ils sont
nombreux à nous vouloir beaucoup de bien
mais aussi parce que ça les intéresse
pas quand on est au travail et la vérité
c'est que nous sommes boulot la vérité
c'est christian jacob nous a demandé
depuis plusieurs mois de mettre un petit
mouchoir sur nos petites ambitions
individuelles sur ce qui nous excite
individuellement de savoir si on est les
plus beaux si on est le meilleur
candidat
si un autre est moins bon que nous non
depuis des mois christian jacob nous a
demandé de nous mettre au travail pour
porter un projet politique
c'est ce qui va intéresser les français
dans les mois qui viennent c'est qu'est
ce que nous voulons faire de ce pays pas
seulement qui nous représentera qu'est
ce que nous voulons faire de ce pays et
voilà des mois que sur le handicap sur
le travail
sur le réchauffement climatique sur
l'autorité de l'état sur l'alimentation
nous multiplions des centaines et des
centaines de forums jamais notre famille
politique n'aura été mobilisés tous les
jours au travail sur le fond comme elle
l'est aujourd'hui et tout ça ça nous
prépare pour les échéances à venir
c'est peut être pas payant immédiatement
mais je peux vous assurer que ça
contribue à notre crédibilité à notre
solidité pour mener la bataille qui
viendra dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent on est en train de charger
le bateau on met des munitions dans le
paquebot monde at-il navire et puis le
moment venu on aura le pilote et pour
répondre au capitaine pour répondre à
votre question sur l'élection régionale
moi je suis confiant d'abord parce que
nous aurons de bons candidats
tous nos présidents sortants celles et
ceux qui sont de notre famille politique
ont été d'excellents président de région
je pense à laurent wauquiez
je pense à xavier bertrand je pense à
valérie pécresse et à tant d'autres qui
aujourd'hui sont à la hauteur de la
belle et difficile mission que leur en
donner leurs habitants et les habitants
de ces belles régions et donc de mais
notre famille politique
son devoir c'est pas de créer de la
division
notre devoir c'est de soutenir celles et
ceux qui porteront le mieux nos couleurs
dans toutes ces régions et dans toutes
les régions qui sont à conquérir
et puis ça va être une élection de plus
pour montrer à quel point la république
en marche est une baudruche un ballot
qui fait semblant d'exister mais qui
n'existe pas les élections municipales
de ce point de vue on était une belle
occasion de montrer qu'il parlait
beaucoup mais qu'ils étaient déracinées
des territoires je pense que ce sera
pire encore pour eux lors des élections
régionales
guy donis pourrons-nous demain adhérer
aux républicains pour quelques euros une
offre à 5 euros par exemple d'abord une
bonne nouvelle le système de réadhésion
notamment en ligne des républicains est
totalement opérationnel joly parce que
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas et ça a
été du travail et vous pouvez donc
adhéré et ré adhérer sans aucun problème
on vous invite à ré adhérer d'ici la fin
de l'année et au d
l'année prochaine c'est très important
parce que il y aura l'année prochaine
des élections internes des moments de
décision important qui vont associer nos
adhérents une préparation de l'élection
présidentielle et donc je veux pas faire
de la survente
je veux simplement vous dire que plutôt
vous serez adhérents ou ré adhérents aux
républicains plus vous aurez la parole
dans les mois qui viennent pour prendre
des décisions et contribue à la décision
importante quant à l'adhésion à 5 euros
m'a coûté c'est une proposition qu'on va
faire faire une opération de black
friday autour des adhésions pourquoi pas
je peux vous dire qu'il y aura une
campagne d'adhésion dans les semaines
qui viennent notamment en début d'année
qui sera une opération massive à
laquelle je vous invite à prendre part
et à relayer autour de vous il suffit
que chacun fasse une adhésion
supplémentaires pour que le mouvement
reprenne encore plus de couleurs
je peux vous dire que nous avons
stabilisé le nombre de nos adhérents ce
qui n'était pas facile
est ce qui est déjà une première
réussite et que pour l'année prochaine
nous aurons en plus de la campagne
d'adhésions auprès de nos adhérents est
né il y aura une campagne particulière
auprès des jeunes toujours dans le cadre
de la rénovation du mouvement des jeunes
républicains
comment expliquez vous cet écart entre
la confiance accordée par les français à
notre famille politique au niveau local
et la confiance rompue au niveau
national si julien de
boulogne-billancourt qui me posent cette
question si on se parle très honnêtement
notre famille politique a essuyé des
échecs électoraux importants celui des
dernières élections présidentielles
celui des élections législatives même si
on est quelques survivants
ça a été un échec et puis celui des
élections européennes
alors je sais que parfois on me demande
de ne pas le dire enfin ce qu'on ait des
responsables politiques lucides on peut
raisonnablement sans jeter l'accusation
sur qui que ce soit constater que nous
avons échoué dès
là plusieurs reprises et pas sur des
petites élections et que ces élections
étaient des chocs électoraux dur pour
nous et si nous ne regardons pas cette
situation dans les yeux on recommencera
et donc notre responsabilité c'est de ne
pas recommencer les mêmes erreurs
parce que lorsqu'on fait 6% à une
élection c'est qu'on a commis des
erreurs et c'est du site que de le dire
et toute cette étape-là nécessite de la
reconstruction
les élections municipales ont été une
étape de reconstruction
les élections sénatoriales nous avons
gagné ont été une seconde étape de
reconstruction les élections
départementales et régionales seront une
troisième étape de reconstruction
parce que nous venons de loin parce que
la confiance a été durement rompu entre
les français nous il faut avancer avec
humilité n'y a pas de solution miracle
je pense que les français nous ferons
confiance s'ils voient que
progressivement nous passons une étape
après l'autre que nous faisons pas les
coques qu'on prétend pas détenir la
vérité c'est que quand on a été punis le
mieux c'est de montrer qu'on a compris
la leçon
est ce que nous faisons depuis plusieurs
mois consiste aussi à montrer aux
français qu on a compris qu'on a compris
qu'il nous fallait aborder les choses
différemment et je pense que tout ça ça
recréer un climat de confiance
on est sûrement passer d'un climat de
défiance en main notre famille politique
un climat de confiance et ce qui ma
confiance
on finira de l'installer avec les
sections départementales et régionales
avant que deviennent une autre étape qui
est celle des élections présidentielles
justement nos amis de rillieux-la-pape
la pape me demande si je suis favorable
ou non à une primaire et pourquoi donc
comme la question m'est posée
personnellement je vais répondre
personnellement je n'engage pas toute
notre famille politique mais vous le
savez je suis tout à fait hostile à la
primaire pour deux raisons la première
c'est que c'est une idée géniale qu'on a
importé de la gauche et que toutes les
idées qu'on a importé de la gauche sont
en général pas des réussites
on n'est donc pas obligé de réitérer la
mauvaise idée
héritée de la gauche la deuxième raison
qui me pousse à être tout à fait hostile
à la primaire c'est que pour moi c'est
une machine à perdre et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi
d'abord parce que c'est une machine qui
étalent au grand jour nos divisions et
c'est vrai que la dernière primaire a
été un moment d'enthousiasmé pour nous
tous parce que pendant des semaines on a
donc indiens ont bataillé pour montrer
qu'elle était le meilleur de tous c'est
vrai mais on a oublié que pendant que
nos candidats bataillent et les français
dont on allait ensuite solliciter les
suffrages nous regarder bataille et de
regarder non candidat montrer leurs
différences par rapport à l'autre et que
le moment venu au moment du
rassemblement
vous pouvez me raconter toutes les
blagues que vous voulez mais quand vous
avez passé des mois à vous tirer la
bourre vous n'arrivez pas à vous
rassembler et la primaire c'est une
machine à installer des divisions des
concurrences qui ensuite ne sont pas
réconciliables voilà pourquoi je ne
crois pas en la primaire et enfin je n'y
crois pas parce que la primaire c'est
contraire à l'idée qu'on se fait du
gaullisme je veux dire à tous mes amis
républicains très gaulliste est en jeu
c'est qu'ils sont sincèrement gaulliste
qu'on ne peut pas être gaulliste et pour
une primaire parce que l'idée du
gaullisme c'est l'idée de la rencontre
du peuple et d'un candidat sans
intermédiaire
peut-être que ça nous fera plaisir
d'avoir une primaire qui désigne un chef
de clan
le chef d'un autre clan moi je serai le
premier à être heureux de choisir celui
qui sera le plus représentatif de notre
clan je serais le premier heureux à le
faire sauf que on ne peut pas choisir un
chef de clan pour ensuite devenir un
chef d'état on se trompe d'élection le
chef de notre famille politique on le
connaît déjà le chef de famille
politique c'est christian jacob
il a été lu par don par les adhérents
voilà le chef de notre famille politique
pour l'étape d'après c'est un chef
d'état qui nous faut trouver et il faut
donc que notre famille politique porte
un homme ou une femme qui soit capable
non seulement de nous rassembler mais de
rassembler les français ça je veux le
dire avec
insistance le le bel avenir de la droite
républicaine
c'est pas de faire 6% le bel avenir la
droite républicaine c'est de faire plus
de 50% ses dents portait les français
avec elle et ce qui fait que nous tous
nous les républicains nous avons été
fiers de jacques chirac lorsqu'un 95 il
devient président de la république c'est
parce que nous nous sommes dit ce jour
là nos idées elles sont capables
d'emporter la majorité du pays et sont
capables de convaincre une majorité de
nos concitoyens
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'en 2017 nous les
républicains la droite républicaine nous
avons été fiers que notre candidat
nicolas sarkozy soit élu parce que nous
sommes dit ce jour là nos idées elles
sont capables de rassembler une majorité
de français mais voilà ce qu'il fait
l'avenir la droite républicaine c'est
pas d'alimenter un fonds de commerce
le bel avenir la droite le week-end
c'est d'être majoritaires dans le pays
c'est de représenter le peuple français
voilà pourquoi je pense que pour réussir
tout ça il faut tout sauf une primaire
suzanne de puget sur durance me dis
aucun militant ne souhaite revivre les
tristes spectacles passé que faire pour
éviter que plusieurs candidats droite ne
se présente je pense que suzanne nous
sommes d'accord sur la question de la
primaire et pardon si je vous ai parlé
un peu franchement mais c'est sûrement
l'objectif aussi de vous dire les choses
comme je les pense très librement pour
moi la primaire est une erreur à ne pas
commettre à nouveau
maintenant il faudra bien qu'on se
décide moi je suis encore un peu
utopiste
parce que je sais dans ma famille
politique il y à des femmes et des
hommes qui sont d'abord guidé par un
sens de la responsabilité et je pense
que parmi toutes les femmes et les
hommes qui aujourd'hui sont prétendument
candidats potentiellement candidats il
croit d'abord en leurs qualités
personnelles et ils ont bien raison mais
je les connais trop pour imaginer qu'il
soit irresponsable
je pense qu'ils sont tous très
responsable et que comme ils sont très
responsables
le moment venu ils les accepterons qu'il
n'y en a qu'un seul qui représente notre
famille
politique sa part tous les amis tous les
candidats plus ou moins déclarés
d'aujourd'hui j'en connais pas un qui
soit ni responsable et parce qu'ils sont
tous responsables
le moment venu je me dis que ils
arriveront nous arriverons à choisir
celui ou celle qui aura le plus de
chances de l'emporter
moi je crois en la responsabilité et je
pense dans notre famille politique nous
avons des femmes et des hommes qui ont
beaucoup de qualités notamment une c'est
d'être responsable et quand on est
responsable en politique on est aussi
capable de pas mener la bataille dont on
sait par avance qu'on ne la gagnera pas
françois d'ang lee ye me dit notre
famille politique sera t elle prête pour
les présidentielles elle fait tout pour
mais elle le fait étape par étape fond
est ce que les français aujourd'hui sont
obsédés par l'élection présidentielle
est ce que le restaurateur qui est
empêchée de réouvrir de travailler et
intéressés par l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que celui qui a perdu son boulot
est intéressé par l'élection
présidentielle est-ce que celui qui est
empêchée de vivre normalement
celui qui souffre au quotidien du
confinement est obsédé par l'élection
présidentielle est ce que les français
sont obsédés par une élection
présidentielle aujourd'hui la réponse
est non et on ne peut pas nous avoir une
obsession que les français n'ont pas ce
serait indécent
aujourd'hui de détaler sur la table nos
petites affaires individuelles
c'est le moment d'être à la hauteur de
la préoccupation des français est dans
un moment où les français souffrent
tellement ou le trouble est si grand et
bien nous devons parler aux français de
notre projet politique c'est pas le
moment d'être déconnecté de ce qui les
intéresse de ce qui les préoccupe c'est
pour ça que notre président christian
jacob ne cesse de 10
tous nos amis que c'est pas le moment de
s'énerver c'est le moment d'être calme
et d'être serein et le moment de
l'élection présidentielle viendra vous
savez jacques chirac lorsqu'il gagne
1,95
il se déclare au mois de novembre et
avant le mois de novembre
il n'est pas le candidat évident de
notre famille politique ça ne l'a pas
empêché de gagner en 95
quant à nicolas sarkozy il s'est déclaré
aussi assez tardivement et avant ça il a
eu quelques concurrents on l'a oublié
mais il a eu quelques concurrents bref
tout ça pour vous dire que le moment
venu une fois les élections régionales
passées
une fois la dernière et sauter et bien
nous arrivons devant une autre étape qui
sera celle de l'élection présidentielle
évidemment que le moment venu nous
serons prêts pour mener cette bataille
ce que je peux simplement vous dire
c'est que nous aurons un candidat à la
présidentielle et que ce candidat aura
toutes les chances de l'emporter
une dernière question celle de denis
d'angoulême qui est une belle question
et je suis heureux de finir sur cette
question là pour vous c'est quoi la
france de demain et bien pour moi denis
sûrement pour vous aussi la france
demain c'est un peu beaucoup
celle d'hier c'est une autre histoire la
france est pas quelque chose d'une nulle
part c'est une grande et belle histoire
sont des grandes et belles valeurs
profondément des inscrits et est
enraciné
mais la france demain c'est aussi celle
qui donnera à l'espoir
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de sens
politique s'il n'y a pas d'espoir la
france c'est celle qui a toujours fait
rêver les plus jeunes ouvriers la
personne la plus modeste comme celui qui
a
qui est un privilégié la france c'est
celle qui est capable de rassembler de
l'ouvrier au patron de la grande
entreprise
la france demeure c'est celle qui
laissera une place à notre jeunesse
c'est celle qui réaffirmera les valeurs
de la république et c'est celle qui
portera une espérance moi je ne crois
pas qu'il puisse y avoir une idée de la
france en une grande idée de l'espérance
et de la justice
c'est un nouveau combat c'est celui de
la france et c'est le combat de la
france qui a souvent rejoint le combat
de la droite et de notre belle famille
politique
voilà pour les questions ou avis poser
ce soir j'espère que vous avez été
heureux d'entendre les réponses entre le
cas j'ai été heureux de vous les donner
et je vous dis à très bientôt pour une
nouvelle séquence de de questions
réponses qui sera toujours avec plaisir
bonne soirée à tous